Umgekehrt vor allem mit einer Grafikkarte.
Anstatt zu einer...
Moment, Moment, der Mutags explodiert da gerade hinten.
Wir haben gerade so fünf Fachbegriffe benutzt, die wir alle noch nicht erläutert haben.
Deswegen versuche ich das gerade mit einer Analogie zu erklären.
Wir haben noch nicht mehr erklärt, was eine Route eigentlich ist.
Ja, eine Route ist halt ein Wegweiser zu einer IP-Adresse.
Genau, ich habe also, eine IP-Adresse existiert nicht alleine, sondern die ist Teil eines Netzwerkes. Von zuhause kennt man dann sowas wie 192.168.1.0 und dann steht dahinter sowas wie 1.24. Das heißt, ich habe 24 Bit von dieser Zahl, die das ist. Und darüber kann ich dann eben sagen, wohin Daten geschickt werden sollen. Und diese Router announceden eben, dieser Netzbereich ist bei mir, das ist eine Route.
Okay.
Das ist der eine Punkt. Backplane hatten wir gerade eben. Das ist das in einem Router, was die verschiedenen Anschlüsse miteinander verbindet und wo wirklich die Daten drüber gehen. Und wenn die halt langsam ist, dann kann der Router auch nicht so viel Daten transportieren.
Das heißt, das ist dann schon wieder spezielle Hardware?
Na, um den Analogie vielleicht fertig zu machen, um das Ganze auch verständlich zu haben. Also man kann halt zum Beispiel sagen, es kreuzen sich zwei Straßen. Und wenn sich zwei Straßen kreuzen, kann man da halt so eine Ampel hinstellen, die jetzt einfach mal die CPU signalisiert. Da kann man auch links, rechts geradeaus fahren. Allerdings muss man halt immer warten und sich genau einordnen. Während so eine Autobahnkreuzung, da macht man dieses Einordnen halt über so einen Kilometer und nimmt dann halt die Kurve auch bei 120 kmh. Und so ähnlich ist, wenn man dieses Routing in Hardware macht. Da kann halt dann wirklich ein spezieller Chip, so ein Paket lesen und weiß dann, wo das hin muss, ohne da jetzt jedes Mal relativ viel Rechenaufwand reinzustecken, sondern der macht das einfach nebenher. Und da kann dann einfach viel mehr an Datenverkehr durchgehen.
Da hast du dann auch nicht 2, 3, 4 Spuren, sondern die laufen übereinander und untereinander und überhaupt.
Und letztendlich Datenverkehr austauschen, schön und gut innerhalb eines Rechenzentrums. Zwischenrechenzentren miete ich mir dann immer selber eine Faser, lege ich selber eine Faser, was mache ich da, um sowohl innerhalb des Rechenzentrums als auch irgendwie zwischen den Rechenzentren kommunizieren zu können, was macht man da üblicherweise?
Also zwischen deinen Rechenzentren kommt ganz drauf an, wo deine Rechenzentren zum Beispiel stehen. Nur zum Beispiel in der Stadt, wenn das jetzt in Berlin ist, du willst zum Rechenzentrum A, zum Rechenzentrum B in Berlin, da sind dann vielleicht 5 km Luftlinie dazwischen. Da mietet man sich tatsächlich eine Glasfaser mit so ein Pärchen, da ist dann komplett leer.
Da kannst du auf der einen Seite reinleuchten und auf der anderen Seite leuchts wieder aus.
Genau, da kümmert so ziemlich keiner drum, was du machst. Da kannst du meinetwegen auch SPDIF drüber fahren und halt deine Boxen ansteuern.
Stopp, SPDIF ist Digital Audio.
Digital Audio mit einem Laserpointer über Plastikkabel in der Regel. Das kann man da auch drüber fahren. Aber du kannst halt auch ganz, ganz viele Daten drüber machen, sodass wir plötzlich über Terrabit reden. Das ist im Idealfall, was man in der Stadt macht. Und jetzt so eine einzelne Faser über das Land zu verlegen, wo wir dann so über 400, 500 Kilometer Strecke reden, ist dann halt natürlich sehr viel aufwendiger. Und da kommen dann auch ganz andere Dinge rein, weswegen man dann sogenannte Wellenlängen mietet.
Ich wollte gerade schon fragen, weil du da sagst, Terrabits über Faser. Ich kenne ja kein Interface, über das man ein Terrabit bekommt.
Da ist doch alles Zeigenkabine.
Die Wellenlängen sind tatsächlich das, was man auf der Langstrecke macht. Aber das macht man natürlich auch in der Metro, also in der Stadt sozusagen, weil eine Faser kann halt ein Signal übertragen. Aber man will halt viel mehr darüber machen, weil das jetzt eine ganze Verschwendung ist. Weil zum Beispiel ein Signal ist ein Gigabit. Und für jedes Gigabit, sich ein Glasfaser zu mieten, das wird dann relativ teuer. Und dann müssten ja viel mehr Glasfasern gebaut werden.
Das heißt, ganz kurz, es gibt zwei Spiele, weiß nicht. Ich kann entweder eine Farbe, das heißt einen Wellenlängenbereich nehmen. Man kann also so einen Faser mit mehreren Wellenlängen gleichzeitig bespielen, wie Licht halt so ist, richtig?
Genau, das ist dann einfach eine Art von Multiplexing, sogenanntes Wave Division Multiplexing, was halt am Ende ist da ein kleiner Prisma drin, der weiß, dass halt gewisse Wellenlängen, Farben, also Farben wirklich nennt man das halt auch in der Regel eine Colored Wave, Colored Optik, dass halt diese Farbe auf den Port 1 muss und die andere Farbe auf den Port 2. Und dann hat man zwei so Geräte an beiden, an jedem Ende, also ein Gerät pro Ende. Und dann schickt man zum Beispiel auf Port 1 eine bestimmte Farbe rein und die kommt am anderen Seite an Port 1 raus. Und dann gibt es halt die Geräte, die haben halt nicht nur ein Port, sondern 48 Ports oder 96 Ports. Sprich, man kann da zum Beispiel 48 verschiedene Farben drauf machen, die am anderen Ende 48 mal rausfallen. Und so kann man halt relativ hohe Kapazitäten über eine wirkliche Glasfaser dann erreichen.
Mit anderen Worten, eine Glasfaser, die ich komplett selber bespielen kann, ist entweder nicht möglich oder geht in Richtung unbezahlbar, wenn man sie nicht selber besetzt.
Das kommt drauf an, wie lang sie ist. Also zum Beispiel in der Stadt machst du das in der Regel selbst. Da kostest du 1.500 Euro im Monat, wenn man da jetzt so die erste Mal kauft. Auf einer Strecke wie von Berlin nach Frankfurt reden wir da plötzlich über 20.000 bis 30.000 Euro im Monat. Wenn du dann tatsächlich von Europa nach Amerika willst, dann musst du da wahrscheinlich ganz am Anfang mehrere Millionen reinwerfen, damit du eine davon kriegen kannst. Dann wird die mitgebaut beim nächsten Mal.
Wie komme ich nach Amerika? Da ist jetzt relativ wenig Land zwischen Europa und Amerika?
Genau, da liegen auch wieder Glasfasern. Die sind eigentlich genau die gleichen, wie sie auch hier in der Stadt liegen. Nur, dass die ein bisschen besser verpackt sind. Da ist dann halt diverse Schutzmechanismen drin, damit wenn das jetzt zehn Jahre über ein Stein scheuert, nicht gleich ein Loch drin ist. Also hat man da so einen dicken Stahlmantel drum. Dann hat man auch wieder so relativ wenige Paare. Aber tatsächlich sind da so zwölf Paare zum Beispiel drin. Und die sind dann halt 5000 Kilometer lang.
Was kann ich dann darüber verfahren, über eine dieser Paare?
Da ist halt dann wieder eine Frage, was du an diesen Multiplexing Equipment da reinsteckst. Also es gibt welche da... Ja, es ist tatsächlich wenig, aber mit aktuellen Multiplexing kriegt man da halt mehrere Terabits ohne Probleme drauf. Und da werden halt die Geräte einfach teurer. Aber dafür hast du halt viel genauere Laser, wo man viel mehr Laser, viel enger aneinander auf viel weniger Wandbreite packen kann. Und dadurch kann man halt dann mal eben einen Terabit da drauf packen. Aber das kostet halt deutlich mehr. Deswegen macht man das in der Stadt nicht, weil da ist die Faser wiederum günstiger.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn es teuer ist, dickere Leitungen zu legen, dann ist es billiger, einen dicken Kompressor an beide Seiten zu packen, die da ordentlich Daten durchjagen. Um das mal so ganz grob zu übersetzen.
Genau, das spielt nur ein anderer Punkt rein. Also zum Beispiel in der Stadt kommst du halt einfach so aus, da ist ein Laser stark genug. Aber bei 5000 Kilometern reicht jetzt so ein Laser halt nicht aus. Also nimmst du diesen Mantel, da ist ja Metall drin, den du zur Schutz vor der Umwelt benutzt. Und dann packst du einfach Strom da drauf. Dann hast du alle 100 oder 200, 300 Kilometer einen Verstärker drin. Und wenn du dann halt einfach mal 1000 Fasern reinmachst, musst du da halt 1000 mal verstärken. Und dann brauchst du halt viel mehr Strom. Und das macht das Ganze halt auch Platz. Und das macht das Ganze dann schwierig. Deswegen werden sich in der Regel auf irgendwie so kleine Faseranzahlen beschränkt. Weil das kann man ohne Probleme vom Land aus auf das Kabel speisen. Und dann hängt da halt irgendwie 20, 30 Repeater auf dem Kabel. Und die funktionieren dann alle noch. Und die sind dann auch nicht so riesig groß. Weil man einfach für zwei Faser nicht so viel Platz braucht. Und auch nicht so viel Strom.
Das heißt, drum landen so Fasern, wenn sie an der Küste entlang gehen, auch öfters mal an. Zum einen, um da abzugreifen. Also um einzelne Fasern aus dem Bündel herauszunehmen. Um Teilstücke von dieser Faser zu benutzen. Alles auch zum Wiederauftanken.
Das heißt, Seekabel sind nichts anderes als ein sehr spezialer Spezialfall der ganz normalen Faser. Das heißt, damit sind wir dann auch durch den Teil durch. Und dann müssten wir uns jetzt mal angucken, jetzt wissen wir wenigstens, wie unsere Daten irgendwie bei anderen Anbietern ankommen. Aber was sie dann machen, wie wir dann letztendlich da unsere Webseite kriegen, das haben wir noch nicht besprochen. Und das machen wir in der nächsten Stunde des Chaos Radio. Danke für's Zuhören. So, und wir sind zurück im Chaos Radio. Die letzte Stunde von zwei zu Gast sind die Herren Kai.
Hallo.
Nimla.
Und Mutaks. So, und wir haben gerade besprochen, wie denn Daten von meinem DSL-Anschluss oder von meinem Handy jetzt irgendwie dann mal in Rechenzentren anlanden.
Und dann sind sie schon fast am Internet.
Wieso fast?
Na ja, ich glaube, wir haben das vorhin schon kurz angerissen, das mit dem ganzen Carrier und auch dem Peering. Deswegen ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen ratlos bin, weil ich was man jetzt noch erzählen soll als nächsten Punkt, weil wir die Timelines zerstört habt.
Wir haben dir die Timelines zerstört? Nein, nein, nein.
Das steht noch diverser Kram.
Diverser Kram. Und da kommt auch noch. Da gibt es einiges, was nämlich der Mutags unbedingt noch besprechen wollte.
Ach du Schande, ich?
Ja, du. Und aus der Nummer kommst du nicht mehr raus.
Weißt du noch, was das war?
Ja, du wolltest mir zum Beispiel erzählen, was es mit DNS Anycast auf sich hat.
Ach du Schande.
Du wolltest was über CDNs erzählen, du wolltest was über DDoS Protection erzählen. Aber fangen wir doch mal ganz ruhig an. In unserer kleinen Vorbereitung hier und auch in dem Titel der Sendung haben wir gesagt Cloud, Cloud, Cloud, Cloud. Wir sind jetzt aber in einzelnen Datenzentren.
Die Cloud klaut meine Daten. Na dazwischen ist noch eine ganze Menge anderes. Ich hab halt irgendwelche Dienstlieder laufen müssen, damit das alles funktioniert. Und an einem Dienst kann man vielleicht noch ein bisschen erklären, was du vorhin gesagt hast, dieses Anycast zum Beispiel. Wir haben ja im Internet so Hostnamen und Webseiten, die haben so Namen wie www.google.com oder www.youtube und so weiter. Das muss ich auf IP-Adressen umsetzen, damit dann eben so was wie der Router überhaupt die Daten transportieren kann. Das heißt, ich hab meinen Rechner, geb da irgendwie die Adresse von der Webseite in meinem Browser ein und muss das übersetzen. Das mach ich mit DNS-Servern. Die sind weltweit verteilt und so ein bisschen sortiert. Das Problem daran ist, wenn man jetzt da so einen oben drüber hätte oder hat, der so die sogenannte Root-Zone verteilt, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt www.google.com auflösen möchte auf eine IP-Adresse, dann teile ich diesen Namen erstmal in einzelne Bestandteile auf und fange von rechts an, das heißt, ich habe das Punkt COM, das ist die Top-Level-Domain COM. Die kommt aus den USA und dann muss ich mir erstmal einen Nameserver suchen, der weiß, wen muss ich denn fragen für alle Namen unterhalb vom Punkt COM? Das ist die sogenannte Root-Zone oder die Root-Nameserver. Wenn ich da jetzt so einen einzigen habe, dann ist der sehr schnell sehr überlastet.
Das ist richtig, dann stelle ich doch einfach mehr dahin.
Dann stelle ich einfach mehr davon hin, aber dann müsste ich ja an die Leute verteilen, welche Adressen die alle haben. Das wird dann irgendwann sehr kompliziert, weil die ändern sich dann und dann ist das doof. Und wenn so ein Host immer nur eine Adresse hat, dann kann ich den ja immer noch überlasten, weil ich habe ja dann diese eine Adresse von diesem Host, dann schiebe ich alles dahin und ich kann ja nicht verhindern, dass alle Leute die selbe Adresse nehmen. Ist das aber so ein Problem, wenn ich dann die selbe Adresse mehrfach verwenden möchte, dann gibt es halt Probleme normalerweise. Also kann jeder zu Hause mal ausprobieren, ich nehme zwei Rechner, schließe sie an das Kabel an und gebe ihnen die selbe IP-Adresse.
Stell dich mir jetzt ungut vor. Aber warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, wir hatten doch vorher dieses BGP, hat das? Ich bin auf dem richtigen Weg.
In der 4th-Zone oder im Internet können wir eben einen Trick anwenden. Wir sagen einfach, naja, es gibt mehrere Rechner, die selber IP-Adresse haben, die stehen aber nicht im selben Data Center, sondern weltweit verteilt. Und per BGP announce ich jetzt dasselbe Netz und dieselbe IP-Adresse. Ein prominentes Beispiel ist die Nameserver, die Google so für jeden anbietet, die 8888 und die 8844, die haben halt diese beiden IP-Adressen.
Du musst das jetzt wie auf Ritz machen, weil du hast jetzt hier eine Person genannt, also eine Firma und dann muss man natürlich auch die Alternativen nennen.
Kennst du die IP-Adresse von OpenDNS zum Beispiel?
Es gibt auch noch die 194, 150, 168, 168.
Oder die 141, 111 von OpenWireless und das davor war von AS250. Und da gibt es auch noch DNS-Cash Berlin CCCDE.
Ich muss jetzt einfach sagen...
Die IP-Adresse, dafür könnt ihr euch im DNS abholen.
Ich muss trotzdem sagen, sorry Leute, die 888 kann ich mir deutlich besser lernen. Ja, ich gebe zu, ich gebe zu, convenience, sie kriegen mich, sie kriegen mich. Dafür habe ich kein Gmail. Doesn't matter.
Okay, also wir haben eine IP-Adresse, ABCD, oder AAAA, 888, ach egal. Und ich habe jetzt mehrere BGP-Router, die diese IP-Adresse, dieses Netzwerk annoucen. Das heißt, die sagen alle, hier bei mir kriegst du diese IP-Adresse, hier bitte die Daten hinschicken. Wir haben vorhin so ganz kurz am Rande erwähnt, wenn ich jetzt so einen BGP-Router betreibe und dann da ganz viele Routen announced bekomme, entscheide ich unter anderem anhand der AS-Fahrtlänge, das heißt anhand der Anzahl an verschiedenen AS, die dazwischen sind bis zum Ziel, wohin ich die Daten schicke. Und normalerweise bevorzuge ich den Fahrt, der am kürzesten ist, weil das geht meistens am schnellsten, der ist am nächsten dabei, Netzwerk-topologisch betrachtet. Wenn ich jetzt aus verschiedenen Richtungen die selbe IP-Adresse announced bekomme, was im Normalfall ja auch der Fall ist, wir haben vorhin gesagt, ich habe mein Netzwerk und ich habe mehrere Ablink-Provider, ich piere also an mehreren Stellen, da announce ich ja auch in jede Richtung die selben IP-Adressen. Weil ich möchte ja von überall die Daten bekommen. Das heißt, es ist der Normalfall, dass ich immer mehrere Wege zum Ziel sehe. Und das macht man sich jetzt dazu zu nutzen, indem ich halt sage, naja, das muss nicht das selbe Ziel sein. Ich habe verschiedene Stellen, die dieselbe IP-Adresse announceen und die, die am nächsten bei mir dabei ist, die bekommt eben den Traffic und kann mir auch antworten. Weil meine IP-Adresse ist ja eindeutig.
Noch mal ein Versuch, da einen Vergleich zu ziehen. Das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen wie stille Post aus verschiedenen Richtungen. Und da wo es...
Das ist so ein bisschen wie wenden sie sich an die nächste Polizeidienststelle. Da ist ja auch nicht gesagt, welche, sondern heißt nur wenden sie sich an die nächste Dienststelle.
Dann wärst du die 1, 2, 2 und dann kommst du bei deiner nächsten 1, 2, 2 Stelle raus.
Das heißt, jedes Mal wenn ich den Google DNS Server anrufe, ist das so ein bisschen so, als wenn ich die Polizei anrufe?
Nicht alles, was hinkt, ist ein Vergleich.
Das stimmt, aber ich denke...
Aber es kann tatsächlich jedes Mal ein anderer Server sein. Und das, was eben da für die Endkunden angeboten wird, das wird genauso für die Route Name Server gemacht und für andere Dienste. Das heißt, ich habe mehrere Server und das heißt auch Attacken, die da gefahren werden, treffen immer nur regional beschränkt bestimmte Server. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt eine verteilte, die Not-of-Service-Attacke habe, das heißt, ganz viel Traffic wird dahin geschickt.
Das heißt also, irgendjemand hat mehrere Rechner übernommen?
Irgendjemand hat da mehrere tausend Rechner übernommen und schickt einfach Unsinnstaten dahin, um den Dienst zu überlasten. Und die kommen jetzt beispielsweise, das ist ja gerade hip, alle aus Russland. Und ich habe jetzt so einen Route Name Server, der in Russland steht, mit dieser IP-Adresse in die Cast. Dann bleibt der Traffic quasi in Russland, weil der Server ist halt da in der Nähe.
Auch wenn sie weltweit verteilt wäre, die Attacke, ist das halt weniger schlimm, wenn du auch weltweit verteilt bist. Dann skalierst du einfach mit gegen deine Attacke und die ist nicht mehr so schlimm.
Das heißt letztendlich, wenn jemand versucht mit russischen Servern, einen DNS-Server, der entsprechend so aufgebaut ist, zu verteilen, dann leidet hauptsächlich die russische Bevölkerung darunter. Oder was immer sich Russland netztopologisch am nächsten fühlt.
Und die Roadname-Server-Betreiber gehen darauf auch ein, wenn sie sehen, da haben sie ein Problem, irgendwo da bräuchte man noch ein, zwei mehr, dann stellen sie da halt ein, zwei mehr einfach mit hin.
Okay, aber ist Anycast etwas, was man jetzt nur, wir sind jetzt extra in die Untiefen des DNS-Systems abgestiegen, um das zu erklären.
Das hat auch einen Grund.
Okay, dann das wollte ich gerade fragen, warum machen wir das jetzt anhand von DNS?
DNS ist ein Dienst, der normalerweise, wenn alles so gut läuft und nicht irgendwelche Spezialfälle eintreten, eigentlich immer UDP benutzt.
So tief brauchen wir gar nicht einsteigen. Du schickst einem DNS-Server eine kleine Anfrage und er schickt dir eine kleine Antwort zurück und ihr baut da keine Verbindung auf. Wenn ich zu einem Webserver, wo ich meine Webseite abrufe, mit dem sprechen möchte, dann bau ich zu dem eine Verbindung auf und die kann eine Weile brauchen. Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Download mache, dann kann der über eine Stunde gehen. Und wenn sich da dann in der Zwischenzeit die Netztopologie verändert und plötzlich ein anderer Server für dich attraktiver wird von der Ernährung im Netz, dann würde deine Verbindung abbrechen, weil der andere Server natürlich von der Verbindung nichts weiß. Bei DNS ist es so, du schickst eine Frage hin, du kriegst ein Paket mit einer Antwort zurück und dann ist gut. Deswegen eignet sich das für so Anycast ganz hervorragend.
Genau, um das ganz kurz zur Vollständigkeit zu halten, das UDP ist das ohne Verbindung und das TCP ist das mit Verbindung, das könnte man jetzt schon mal gehört haben.
Anycast haben wir gesagt, das andere, wo es irgendwie noch vorteilhaft ist, irgendwie ins gesamte Internet sprechen zu können, sind CDNs. Das heißt, das sind?
Das sind Leute, die sowas wie Anycast Netze betreiben, mit noch Magie da drüber und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, zum Beispiel sind der CCC und wir haben jetzt hier monatlich ein Software releasen, das muss auf alle Rechner in der Welt ganz, ganz schnell kommen.
Nein, nein, nein. Oder angenommen.
Angenommen würden wir regelmäßig CCC.de updaten und die Leute klicken da drauf.
Da ist aber nicht so viel Content drauf, da rentiert sich das nicht.
Genau, z.B. jetzt jemand so was wie, nimm mal eine große deutsche Newsseite. Und die muss natürlich schnell laden, von überall. Wenn man jetzt einen Server davon nach Deutschland stellt, dann legt der halt aus Amerika so ein bisschen zäh. Und aus Afrika gar nicht. Wirklich schnell. Und dann kann man sagen so, naja klar, dann stellen wir halt einen Server nach Afrika und einen Server nach Amerika, aber du willst das in der Regel dann nicht selbst betreiben, außer du bist halt wirklich ein Netzwerkmensch oder so.
Das heißt irgendwie, das ist für den Zweck gut, dass du jedes ADHS-Eichhörnchen auf der Welt zufriedenstehen willst, dass das irgendwie ungeduldig wird, wenn nach 10 Millisekunden die Webseite nicht da ist.
Oder du einfach mal riesige Dateien ausliefern musst, wie zum Beispiel ein Update für dein Telefon. Und wenn das jetzt jeder von einem Server zieht, der mit Gigabit am Internet hängt, dann ist das eine langwierige Sache, bis dein Telefon geupdatet ist. Also gibst du einen Koffer voll Geld und einen Koffer voll Daten zu einem sogenannten CDN, was ein Content Delivery Network ist, deren Geschäftszweck ist es sozusagen, Daten an allen Ecken und Enden der Welt eben schnell bereitzustellen, sodass sich keiner beschwert.
Gibt es außerdem noch Use Cases von CDNs?
Also zum Beispiel Media, CCC, CDE liegt auf dem CDN, weil sonst hätten wir nur einen Rechner, an dem das Ganze hängt, und der wäre vielleicht mal überlastet nach dem Kongress. Aber mit so einem CDN kann man das halt einfach mal auf diversen Rechner an diversen Standorten verteilen.
Und du kannst bei so einem CDN auch noch andere Dienste kaufen, sowas wie, naja, wir haben diese Daten, aber die braucht man nur so zweimal im Jahr. Also miete ich halt für diese Zeiträume, in denen ich die Daten halt wirklich anbieten möchte, die Ressourcen beim CDN. Du musst halt nicht selber weltweit Server hinstellen, weil das wäre halt die Alternative. Ich kaufe mir halt ein paar Hundert Server oder miete die irgendwo in irgendwelchen, ja, so Hostern und mache das alles selber. Es ist halt Aufwand und das ist schwierig. Und dann muss ich wissen, wo sind eigentlich meine Kunden und wie viele Kunden habe ich da und ich kann so schnell gar nicht reagieren. Und nach zwei Monaten brauche ich das alles nicht mehr. Ist halt einfacher, dann da jemanden zu beauftragen, der sich damit auskennt.
Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie temporär skalieren muss, ist das eine Möglichkeit, jetzt nicht eigene Hardware anzuschaffen, sondern einfach mal kurzfristig zu sagen, hier, mein Download-Server, der schafft das eigentlich. Die meiste Zeit, aber jetzt in den zwei Wochen, schaff ich das nicht alleine.
Ich hab jetzt hier eine super tolle neue App gebaut und die wird jetzt auf allen Newsportalen nächste Woche gehypt oder nächsten Monat. Vielleicht bereite ich mich da schon mal drauf vor und kauf dann für diesen einen Monat da ein bisschen Ressourcen bei so einem CDN.
Und es gibt dann auch den Fall, dass man eben ein Businessmodell hat, was einfach mit vielen Usern klarkommen muss, wie soziale Netzwerke und so weiter. Da lohnt es sich dann tatsächlich selber, so ein CDN zu bauen und weltweit zu verteilen.
Das heißt, so was wie ein Facebook betreibt sein CDN auch durchaus selber?
Genau.
Was sind denn so CDN-Anbieter? Kennt man die so normalerweise?
Die kennt man vielleicht, wenn man in seinem Browser ganz aufmerksam in die Adressleiste geguckt hat. Weil manchmal sieht man dann tatsächlich, dass der Content, den man da guckt, nicht mehr von der eigentlichen Seite kommt, sondern dass zum Beispiel ein Download-Link von irgendeinem dieser CDN-Betreiber eben kommt.
Oder dass das Leiste Haus bei Akamai liegt, glaube ich. Also die Webseite vom Weißen Haus liegt halt auch in so einem CDN mit drin. Und wenn man dann so die HTTPS-Verbindung aufbaut, poppt dann da plötzlich ein komischer Name im Zertifikat auf.
Hausten unsere Öffentlich-Rechtlichen eigentlich zum Beispiel selber oder lassen die das auch machen?
Also ich glaube, Bundestag zum Beispiel liegt auch gerade auf einem CDN.
Bundestag liegt gerade auf einem CDN, aber Öffentlich-Rechtliche waren jetzt die so ZDF-ID. Ich glaube ZDF, die Mediathek liegt definitiv auf dem CDN.
Ja, das hat aber für die eine Firma selber gebaut, glaube ich.
Ja, das war ein Custom-Geklöppel, das ist.
Das Problem, die Sache bei einer Mediathek für Öffentlich-Rechtliche in Deutschland ist auch, dass deine Zielgruppe nicht geodivers ist, sondern dass die Zielgruppe halt in Deutschland ist. Und da reicht es aus, wenn man eben in Europa ein paar Server stehen hat. Während wenn du jetzt sowas wie bundestag.de oder so hast, dann...
Also bundestag.de nimmt es wahrscheinlich zum Beispiel aus einem anderen Grund. Also CDNs ist halt der eine Punkt, wo du halt datenschnell liefern willst. Aber ein CDN ist auch zum Beispiel ein super Ding, um sich hinter zu verstecken. Weil wenn jetzt mein Server plattgemacht wird mit einer Attacke, dann soll die das mal bitte beim CDN versuchen, was ein paar Tausend Server hat.
Das ist genau das Ding. Also ein CDN ist dafür da, wie du schon sagst, Daten schnell auszuliefern. Und so eine normale Denial-of-Service-Attacke zum Beispiel, wo der Angreifer es darauf ansetzt, den Server durch Anfragen zu überlasten, funktioniert genauso, dass da viele Anfragen gestellt werden, wenn man dann so ein CDN hat, was einfach viele Anfragen beantworten kann.
Ist das eine Verschwörungstheorie, wenn ich sage, dass man sich so ein Business Case für ein CDN selber bauen kann?
Das nennt sich nicht Verschwörung, sondern Vertrieb.
Also das ist tatsächlich so eine schöne Webseite, die sie da haben. Wäre doch schade, wenn der...
Naja, auf der anderen Richtung gibt es das Geschäftsmodell gerade sehr aktiv. Das heißt, ich habe halt so meinen Webshop oder so was. Vielleicht ist auch nicht so ein ganz großes Unternehmen, das so viel Geld hat, so ein CDN-Anbieter zu beauftragen. Nehmen wir mal an, ich bin da irgendwie so mein Webshop, der gerade so gut läuft. Und dann kriege ich halt so eine E-Mail so, wir machen jetzt mal für eine Stunde übrigens gleich der Webshop platt und wir zeigen dir, dass das geht. Und wenn du uns jetzt nicht Geld überweist, mehr oder weniger regelmäßig, machen wir das jetzt halt auch häufiger. Und du kriegst halt dann so eine DINAROUS-SERVICE-ATTACKE, die läuft dann irgendwie 10 Minuten bis eine Stunde oder so. Du kriegst Panik, weil es funktioniert nichts mehr. Dann liest du diese E-Mail und hast halt einen ganz klassischen Erpressungsfall.
Und dann habe ich letztendlich die Wahl, zahle ich oder nehme ich für möglicherweise etwas weniger Geld die Dienste von so einem CDN in Anspruch.
Das Problem, das hört man mich noch, das Problem, an dem zahle ich, das hört halt dann nicht auf, wie das bei Erpressungen so üblich ist. Weil das hat einmal funktioniert, warum soll es nicht zweimal funktionieren? Oder dreimal oder fünfmal?
Mit Mengen, Robert.
Genau. Das heißt, wir haben gelernt, es gibt sehr, sehr viele Anwendungsfälle für CDNs. Und im Endeffekt ist es alles nur dazu da, dass ich, wenn ich zu Hause hinter meinem kleinen DSL-Router sitze, mit dem wir vor etwas mehr als eineinhalb Viertelstunden angefangen haben, irgendwie zuverlässig irgendwie YouTube gucken kann.
Genau. Das ist allerdings jetzt auch noch mal ein anderer Spezialfall. Es gibt nicht nur diese statischen CDNs, wo ich dann sage, ich hab hier meinen Content, ich geb dir eine Festplatte oder ich gruppier den da auf einen Server bei dir. Es gibt auch noch diese dynamischen Sachen, wie gerade eben aus YouTube angesprochen, das macht. YouTube gehört ja zu Google und die haben dann Google Caches, die durchaus auch mal bei den Provider stehen. Also ich hab also eine Bewegung, die immer näher zum Endkunden geht. Wir hatten vorher gesagt, ich hab das CDN, weil es mir nicht viel bringt, einen Server nur in Deutschland zu haben, wenn das aus den USA abgerufen wird. Also habe ich das CDN mit den Servern, die auch in den USA stehen. Der nächste Schritt ist eben, ich stelle diese Zwischenschweicher, diese Caches eben direkt in das Provider-Netzwerk, in den Backbone von meinem ISP, wo die ganzen Endkunden dran sind.
Machen die großen CDNs tatsächlich auch?
Genau, darauf wollte ich halt genau raus.
Ich dachte, es ginge immer nur darum, ein gutes Peering, also eine gute Verbindung mit denen zu haben.
Naja, das beste Peering ist, wenn du das Ding den Leuten in die eigene Hütte stellst.
Gut, das stimmt natürlich.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel in Deutschland was betreibst und du hast so CDNs und dann hast du halt nicht nur 1 Gigabit, sondern so 200 Gigabit zu dem CDN und wieso jetzt den gesamten Traffic erst mal nach Frankfurt und Düsseldorf transportieren, wenn du auch jeweils 20 Gigabit in jeder kleinen Stadt haben kannst, wo du ein bisschen mehr Technik hast.
Also ich hätte jetzt tatsächlich gedacht, dass der Traffic, der so ausgeliefert wird, so divers ist, dass sich so ein lokaler Cash mit begrenztem Speicher nicht lohnt. Ja, es ist wirklich so, dass alle Leute nur Cat-Content gucken und über das eine Video...
Das ist die Magie, die ich am Anfang erwähnte. Wenn man einfach sagen könnte, hier sind Daten und verteile mal, dann würde das halt jeder machen. Aber tatsächlich gibt es halt große CDNs, die wirklich viel benutzt werden, weil diese Magie einfach stimmt. Das ist dann halt eine ganz große Kombination aus Sachen wie, wo sitzt der User, was braucht er für Content, welche Rechtsregionen passt dahin, wie viel kostet der Strom, wo die Daten verfügbar sind, wie viel kostet der Traffic dahin zum Provider, ist die Strecke niedrig hochlatent, ist sie schnell oder langsam, ist da Packet loss oder nicht, wie wichtig ist der Content. Da spielen halt 25.000 Sachen mit rein, wo dann bei so großen CDNs entschieden wird, dahin wird der Traffic jetzt also von diesem Punkt wieder ausgeliefert. Und da ist halt die Präferenz natürlich bei diesen Servern, die halt direkt im Backbone stehen, aber du kannst ja so einen Server auch nicht endlos befüllen. Und dann gibt es wiederum sogenannte Algorithmen dafür, die sich dann darum kümmern, dass immer der richtige Content mit der besten Success-Hitrate sozusagen auf diesen Servern liegt. Also Hitrate ist das halt, dass man sagt, da versuchen wir so viel möglich dran zu haben. Und es bringt halt jetzt nichts irgendwie, zum Beispiel, wenn in Deutschland ein Apple-Update released wird, dann muss das Apple-Update halt auf den Servern gerade liegen an dem Moment. Und das Microsoft-Update von vor einer Woche ist dann halt weniger interessant oder halt andersrum. Beziehungsweise, ich weiß nicht, wenn die Queen spricht, ist das jetzt für Deutschland weniger interessant. Also muss man das jetzt nicht unbedingt so auf deutschen Servern abwickeln, aber dafür richtig viel auf englischen Servern.
Das Ganze wird dann noch komplexer, wenn du eine bestimmte Dienstgüte zusichern möchtest für einen Download zum Beispiel. Da bringt es dir dann wenig, wenn du alle Teilnehmer auf den jeweils lokalen Node legst. Wenn das ein längerer Download ist, dann kannst du aber sagen, wenn der zu so und so voll ist, dann geht es um den zweitschlechteren, weil der immer noch eine höhere Datenrate liefert als der erste. Also da steckt ganz viel den Content und die User kennen, unser Netz kennen und das in Korrelation setzen.
Zwei Fragen. Erstens, möchte man überhaupt noch größere Dienste ohne ein CDN betreiben?
Ja, kommt auf den Dienst an. Also sagt den Dienst und ich sag dir das, aber weißt jetzt nicht, müsste man halt Case by Case entscheiden. Ich kann jetzt nicht pauschal sagen, so wie...
Ganz spannender Fall, Voice over IP.
Ja.
Das kannst du nicht ins CDN?
Ja, absolut, weil das eine 1 zu 1 Verbindung ist. Nee, aber das klingt jetzt so, wenn ich quasi in so einer Broadcast-Situation bin, das heißt ich zu, zum Rest der Welt, was ja eigentlich, ich denke mal, bei den meisten Diensten der Normalfall ist und irgendwie eine gewisse Wichtigkeit erreicht habe, dass ich dann eigentlich um so ein CDN nicht drum rumkomme. Egal, ob selbst betrieben, also die spannende Frage ist wahrscheinlich auch nochmal, kann ich mir, oder könnte ich mir, es ist natürlich immer noch die Frage, dass man Leute hat, die sowas betreiben. Wir haben gerade gehört, der CCC hat irgendwie selber ein CDN am Start für Videos. Das heißt, es scheint auch selber zu gehen, aber will ich in der Regel diese Magic haben?
Sie kosten natürlich am Ende in der Regel Geld. Also da muss ich halt wirklich hinsetzen und sage es halt so, ist mir diese Magic und diese mehr User Experience das wert oder merken das meine User eh nicht, weil die surfen nur aus Berlin oder die haben eh nur 56k Modems, brauchen die es überhaupt schnell?
Oder ist es okay, wenn der Download halt irgendwie fünf Minuten länger dauert bei dem Video, was drei Stunden geht? Bei so einer Organisation wie dem CCC ist das jetzt nicht so geschäftskritisch, dass die Leute sich den Stream oder den Podcast ein bisschen später runterladen, weil sie sowieso die Videos alle vom Kongress ziehen, während so ein Software Update vielleicht schon ein bisschen kritischer ist, weil ich das nicht möchte, dass sich das ewig hinzieht und dauernd abrichtend Leute neu versuchen, weil da wären sie böse und dann sind sie sauer auf meine Firma und dann kaufen sie mein Produkt nicht mehr.
Man muss da aber auch mal unsere User loben, ihr zieht euch das ja eh auch über betorrent. Brauchen wir gar kein CDN.
Wobei unser CDN tatsächlich auch betorrent Support hat, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Das heißt, wenn du eine Datei runterlätst, Achtung, Nordalarm wieder, du kriegst die nächsten Download-Server dann als HTTP Seats.
Das heißt, dein betorrent client spricht nicht nur dieses esoterische Hacker-betorrent-Protokoll, sondern auch das HTTP.
Genau, und dann kannst du dir quasi, solange betorrent tot rostet, das ist ja gerade am Anfang immer der Fall, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel gleich fertig sind, plus die Zeit, die wir brauchen, um die Sendung hier zu schneiden, dann damit die ersten dann quasi trotzdem ganz schnell herunterladen können, auch wenn auch niemand anders da per betorrent Sachen raushaut, können sie halt immer noch ihre nächsten Download-Server mit reinnehmen. Das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Lösung.
Jetzt haben wir also gesprochen, wie wir skalieren können, wenn wir Daten verteilen wollen, aber jetzt habe ich eigentlich noch mal kurz eine Frage dazu, die kommt aus dem Publikum mehr oder weniger.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die zu nerdig ist, aber z.B. man hat ja z.B. so eine Webseite, wo z.B. Webmail liegt oder ein Webshop und da ist ja immer dieses HTTPS und so ein grünes Schlüsselding davor. Will man dann diesen Private Key, also sozusagen deinen Schlüssel, um das ganze Krypto aufzumachen, will man den dann so auf 1000 Servern in der Welt bei einem Drittanbieter liegen haben?
Das ist eine hervorragende Frage, will man eigentlich nicht. Aber das Weißhaus macht das, die vertrauende Ackermai. Wenn ich jetzt so einen CDN habe, was nur Daten verteilt, dann komme ich da so ein bisschen drum rum, weil der Download-Server hat eine andere URL, die kann ein Certifikat haben mit einem eigenen Key, hat mit meiner Webseite nicht viel zu tun. Der Webshop wird ja meistens auch irgendwie eine zentrale Instanz haben, weil das auf einen CDN zu packen ist jetzt nicht so trivial, weil dann landen Leute dann auf einem anderen Server und das ist dann doof und dann habe ich keine zentrale Buchhaltung und das geht alles kaputt. Das heißt, da hat man sowieso andere Maßnahmen davor. Und ich glaube Nibbler explodiert hier gleich. Du hast da gerade eben ganz, ganz viel geschüttelt.
Da hatte ich zum Glück den Keks noch im Mund.
Ansonsten ist das natürlich ein Problem. Ich kann natürlich verschiedene Zertifikate mit verschiedenen Keys haben. Das heißt, man kann dann immer nur die eine Verbindung aufmachen. Aber das ist natürlich dann eine Überlegung, die man sich machen muss. Ich glaube, da gab es jetzt auch gerade Diskussionen, dass der Bundestag.de gerade hinter Cloud für glaub ich ist. Das ist ein amerikanischer Anbieter für die CDNs und DDoS Protection. Und wenn man da TPS drüber spricht, dann können die natürlich die Daten alle mitlesen.
Cloudflare.
Jetzt diffamieren unsere amerikanischen Freunde nicht so.
Und jetzt müssen wir auch wieder andere Namen nennen, weil es gibt halt auch noch andere CDNs. Wenn ihr mal nachsuchen wollt, was sie zum Beispiel machen.
Limelight?
Gibt's Limelight, Akamai, Cloudflare hatten wir jetzt. Wen haben wir noch? Ich glaube, ich sollte mehr kennen.
Ja, ich sehe schon Kai. Wir sollten es halt jetzt über Auftrag nennen, definitiv.
Nee, ich mach nur das, was der Markus macht, weil der fällt dann ja auch ins Wort.
Ja, ich muss das hier nicht machen, weil wir senden hier nicht auf Fritz.
Ja, aber dann ist CCC wieder irgendwie befürwortend für andere und wir machen eine Empfehlung.
Und ich bin Angestellter des Landes Berlin, ich muss darauf passen.
Vorbildlich. Ja, das heißt, jetzt haben wir einmal die CDNs durchgekaut.
Na, aber es gibt ja noch was anderes.
Aha, das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen. Sind wir fertig?
Du hattest ja früh mit der Cloud angefangen. Ich würde jetzt noch nicht CDNs direkt als Cloud bezeichnen, weil Cloud ist normalerweise so vom Verständnis her ein bisschen nur was anderes.
Was sind die Cloud?
Die Cloud sind Computer von anderen Leuten.
So, und kleiner Vorschlag, wir spielen jetzt eine kleine Musik.
Voll dafür.
Und dann beschäftigen wir uns zum einen noch damit, was eigentlich jetzt genau die Cloud sonst noch ist, außer CDNs. Und wir schauen mal nach, wenn das Internet wackelt, woran kann das eigentlich liegen? Das hören wir gleich. Ich glaube es ist Zeit, die Tür abzulegen. So, willkommen zurück in der letzten halben Stunde Chaosradio 213. Das war Magna mit Divide. Das ist Netzmusik, die ihr euch runterladen könnt. Ich denke, die werden wir gleich noch in den Show Notes verlinken.
Von dem CDN?
Von einem CDN vermutlich und der, der da reinquatscht, das ist der Mutax.
Hallo.
Dann haben wir noch den Nibbler.
Und den Kai. Hallo. So.
Ich unterbrech dich an der Stelle mal mit einem großartigen Witz.
Oh Gott.
Give me a strong cider please because I'm exhausted. Die nächste halbe Stunde sollten wir mit einem Thema füllen können.
Ich glaube auch. Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo. Ich glaube, ich muss wieder den Markus holen.
Herzlich willkommen beim Chaosradio.
So. Ich will hier raus.
Kommst du nicht.
Mist. Aber das Schöne ist ja, als Moderator kann ich euch verpflichten, Dinge zu erklären. Und der Mutaxe hat sich gerade bereit erklärt. Es hat aber wunderbar funktioniert. Wir haben eineinhalb Stunden voll bekommen. So, und die letzte machen wir auch noch, weil der Mutaxe erklärt uns jetzt, warum CDNs nicht alles sind, wenn wir von Cloud reden. So, bitte.
Ja, Cloud sind ja wie gesagt anderer Leute Computer. Und das sind jetzt nicht Kühlschränke.
Gibt es auch schon ziemlich lange. Früher hat man das Mainframe genannt.
Genau. Mainframe ist halt dann so der Zentralrechner. Und irgendwie gehen wir so langsam wieder in diese Richtung zurück. Wir haben jetzt so unsere kleinen Taschencomputer, die nur noch so ein Frontend mit einer App sind für einen Großrechner. Und das Problem ist, dass so ein einzelner Großrechner hinter nicht mehr reicht, wir haben ja, wie du gesagt hast, der Webshop im CDM, das funktioniert halt nicht so ganz, weil der Webshop ist halt eine aktive Anwendung. Und wenn ich die verteile und die Leute dauernd auf einen anderen Server kommen, gehen halt Sachen kaputt. Das heißt, ich muss meine Anwendung halt so bauen, dass sie skaliert über mehrere Server hinweg. Dann habe ich aber auch wieder das Problem, naja, eigene Server kaufen ist halt doof, weil mein Webshop wird halt nicht 24 mal 7 immer komplett benutzt, weil ich habe halt irgendwie so Geschäftszeiten vielleicht.
Ladenöffnungszeiten.
Genau, vielleicht verkaufe ich ja auch irgendwie erotischen Inhalt, dann darf ich das erst ab 22 Uhr in Deutschland machen. Dann brauche ich tagsüber den Webshop ja gar nicht. Und so habe ich halt verschiedene Lastkurven auf meinen Servern drauf. Und immer für die maximale Last alle Ressourcen bereitzuhalten, ist halt auf Dauer relativ teuer. Das braucht Strom, das braucht Platz. Und im Zuge dieser ganzen Virtualisierungsgeschichten, die es in den letzten Jahren immer mehr gab, kam halt dann auch irgendwann so was wie die Cloud. Die Cloud ist halt ganz wolkig, weil man kann da nicht durchgucken, man sieht ja nicht genau was passiert, aber am Ende kommt da unten Wasser raus. Und man kann jetzt behaupten, na okay, das heißt die Daten der anderen regnen so auf alle Leute, wenn die Cloud undicht ist, weil dann sind die halt Daten so verteilt überall. Das ist die eine Geschichte, aber eigentlich ist es so für mich als Anbieter relativ praktisch, weil ich bezahle eventuell so einen Cloud-Dienstleister nach so einer Metrik wie ich bezahle nur die CPU-Zeit, die ich wirklich brauche und wenn mein Webshop gerade nicht gebraucht wird, dann ist da auch kein Server, der den irgendwie laufen lässt, weil ich habe einen physikalischen Rechner, auf dem ich dann hunderte virtuelle Maschinen habe und jeder dieser Maschinen gehört dann irgendeinem anderen Kunden. Und damit kann ich halt sehr schnell skalieren, wenn ich plötzlich solche Loadpeaks habe, wie zum Beispiel zu Silvester verschicken die Leute ganz, ganz viele SMS und dann brauche ich ganz viele Server, die die SMS handeln, den Rest des Jahres kann ich benutzen um meine Rechnungen zu schreiben und andere Dinge zu tun für die ich vielleicht mehr brauchen kann. Und dann komme ich eben in den Bereich dieser Cloud Dienstleister und das ist für Start-ups auch eine schöne Möglichkeit natürlich. Ich habe dann irgendwie meine geile Applikation, so mein Cloud Backup oder sowas, und plötzlich werde ich dann von Kunden überrannt und brauche ganz viel Speicher und ganz viel Server und dann sind da plötzlich ganz viele in den USA, neue Kunden von mir. Jetzt kann ich da aber nicht einfach so Server hinstellen, habe da auch keine Leute. Also klicke ich mir dann in irgendeinem Cloud Provider meine virtuellen Maschinen zusammen und sage halt, ich brauche jetzt noch 500 mehr, weil ich habe plötzlich ganz viele Kunden dazugekommen. Und wenn meine Applikation das kann, dann skaliert das vielleicht sogar auch.
Aber eine wirkliche Garantie, da fange ich jetzt direkt mal an, eine wirkliche Garantie, dass meine Daten irgendwie datenschutzrechtlich nicht sicher sind, das lassen wir mal ganz völlig.
Das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Sache.
Aber mal abgesehen davon, genau, wie sicher kann ich denn überhaupt sein, dass quasi der Teil meiner Maschine, auf den ich da zeitlich und auch sonst wie Zugriff habe, wirklich meiner ist und war?
Genau. Man kann auch so schöne Kardinalsfehler machen. Es passiert ja ab und zu mal, dass so ein Cloud-Provider teilweise ausfällt. Und ich muss jetzt gerade wieder so ein konkretes Beispiel nehmen. So Amazon, die EC2 Cloud, hat da verschiedene Verfügbarkeitszonen. Ich kann halt sagen, ich möchte irgendwie in Nordamerika verfügbar sein oder ich möchte auch in Europaserver haben oder in Asien oder sowas. Und vielleicht möchte ich auch Ausfallsicherheit haben. Die muss ich aber extra bezahlen und dazu buchen. Und wenn ich dann so eine Start-up-Firma bin, die Herzpatienten überwacht und ihre Herzdaten aufbereitet, damit Ärzte darauf zugreifen können, ist es nicht so eine ganz gute Idee, wenn ich nur eine Verfügbarkeitszone buche und die dann ausfällt.
Warte, warte, warte. Da gibt es wirklich Leute, die wichtige medizinische Dienste auf Amazon laufen lassen.
Amerika. Und der Arzt kann halt dann im Webinterface gucken, wie es seinen Patienten so geht und welche davon kurz vor einem Herzanfall stehen und kann dann jemanden vorbeischicken oder gucken, wie es denen geht.
Hoffentlich nur der Arzt.
Hoffentlich nur der Arzt, vielleicht auch nicht.
Und der Admin von der EC2.
Es ist ja alles harmlos, weil man möchte ja, dass da jemand vorbeikommt, bevor der tot ist. Das Problem war halt nur, es gab dann so dieses Supportforum und da hat dann jemand sehr, sehr aufgeregt drin geschrieben, könnt ihr das nicht machen, dass die Cloud-Plattform ganz schnell wieder da ist, weil wir wissen nicht, ob unsere Patienten noch leben.
Gut, das heißt...
Ist aber im Grunde dasselbe wie auch bei klassischer Rechenzentrumsplanung. Da hat man zwei Stromleitungen in seinen Rack rein, wenn man die Server nur an die eine anschließ. Oder die eine Hälfte an die eine, die andere Hälfte an die andere. Und nicht die zwei Netzteile, die da renundant im Server drin. Eins links, eins rechts. An die Stromleitungen. Also wann immer man Infrastruktur plant, sollte man sich halt mal angucken, das worauf ich das baue. Was kann das leisten? Und dass das, was es leisten kann, mir genug für das, was ich an Dienst anbieten möchte.
Das heißt so, dass das Takeaway von dieser Sache ist, ich muss unterscheiden. Davon bin ich sowieso nicht ausgegangen. Aber die zwei wichtigen Sachen. Erstens, planen muss ich, egal ob ich Cloud mache oder nicht. Das ist einfach Admin-Pflicht, meine Infrastruktur vorher sorgfältig zu planen, auch auf mögliche Ausfälle hin. Und das andere ist, Datensicherheit in der Cloud ist in mehrfacher Hinsicht ein Problem.
Du hast auch noch ein ganz, ganz schönes anderes Problem bei dieser ganzen Cloud, ist auch schon vorgekommen. Es gibt dann da so Anbieter, die bieten dir ganz, ganz sicheres Hosting für Source Code oder für deine Daten an. Und dann gibt es dann da so einen Admin, der dann da so sein Passwort eventuell versehentlich veröffentlicht. Oder wie auch immer bekommt jemand Zugriff auf dieses eine Webinterface von dem Cloud-Anbieter. Und da gibt es diesen großen roten Knopf Shutdown oder Delete. Und dann ist halt alles weg und weg ab auch. Und dann gibt es auch diese Firma nicht mehr. Auch vorgekommen.
Also auch das, auch da nur weil man irgendwas in die Cloud abgibt.
In der Cloud kann ich die Sachen auch sehr, sehr schnell und effizient löschen. Das ist halt der Vorteil von Virtualisierung. Im Gegensatz zu physikalischer Hardware. Da muss ich mit dem Hammer draufhauen oder auf jeden Server einzeln gehen. Wenn ich jetzt nicht so ein zentrales Konfigurationsmanagement habe. Bei der Cloud ist das halt ein Klick.
Also im Zweifelsfall ist es dann auch nur für mich gelöscht. Und die falschen Leute können immer noch drauf zugreifen.
Gut, umgekehrt möchtest du halt auch nicht, dass du da Daten hast und wenn sie gelöscht markiert sind. Kommt auch vor.
Kommt absolut bestimmt auch vor.
Löschen setzt doch eh nur das Flagg für deleted auf true in der Datenmark, oder?
Es geht doch auch kein Andelit mehr. Bei Gmail kann ich meine Mails jetzt auch 15 Sekunden lang wieder zurückziehen.
So, wälz weiter dumm, ich laber, darf die nächste Sendung moderieren. So, haben wir noch irgendwas wichtiges zur Cloud vergessen? Wahrscheinlich könnten wir da auch wieder ein ganzes Thema zu aufmachen. Der was bitte?
Der Fockcomputing.
Der Nebel, das ist noch undurchsichtiger.
Kannst du das anreißen, ohne dass wir da wieder ein halbstündiges Element draus machen?
Das ist Marketing von einem großen deutschen Telekom Provider oder so. Nee, es gibt so Aufkleber, da steht das drauf.
Okay, dann lass uns da besser nicht genauer drauf eingehen.
Um das nochmal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, wenn euch irgendjemand Wolken oder irgendetwas anderes verkauft, fragt mal lieber nach, was ihr da wirklich bekommt.
Genau, also es ist ein schwammiges Wort für ein nicht greifbares Produkt. Passt auf. So, dann ist natürlich noch die Frage, das Internet kann wackeln?
Das Internet kann wackeln.
Warum? Wir haben doch gelernt, das ist doch ganz toll. Wir haben das Internet organisiert in diese wunderschönen autonomen Systeme und die machen das unter sich aus. Ich will nur mal kaputulieren, was ich verstanden habe. Dann müsst ihr mir erklären, warum das trotzdem kaputt gehen kann. Also, ich habe diese schönen Autonomensysteme. Innerhalb des Autonomensystems kann ein Anbieter, der dieses Autonomensystem verwaltet, Mist bauen und untereinander erzählen die sich letztendlich nur, wer sie sind. Warum kann da jetzt was kaputt gehen?
Na, da sind halt immer Menschen beteiligt und Menschen machen Fehler.
Aha, und diese Fehler können... Also, das mit dem Bagger hatten wir ja durchaus schon.
Also auf so einer BGP-Session zum Beispiel, wo sich die Rechner gegenseitig miteinander unterhalten. Weil ich glaube, du spielst auf einen ganz bestimmten Ausfall an.
Ja, dann erzähl mir doch mal, was du glaubst, was ich meine.
Und zwar, das haben vielleicht Leute mitbekommen am 12.06. die kleine Outage mit Malaysia Telecom.
Okay, warte mal, was interessiert mich denn Malaysia? Ich bin noch hier und ich möchte irgendwie YouTube Sachen gucken, die irgendwie in den USA sind oder wie wir gelernt haben, möglicherweise auch direkt in die Ecke. Was interessiert mich Malaysia Telecom?
Wenn die Malaysia Telecom nämlich plötzlich sagt, das gesamte Internet ist bei mir, dann interessiert dich das schon.
Moment, erstens, warum tut sie das? Zweitens, warum darf sie das? Drittens, warum kann sie das?
Tja, das kann sich alles auf das Wort Filter reduzieren, glaube ich. Und zwar diese ganzen BGP-Sessions. Da wird erstmal so, im Standardfall wird da alles rausgeschmissen und alles angenommen, was drüber reinkommt. Um das Ganze jetzt damit halt nicht irgendwie ich hingehen kann und sage ich bin jetzt irgendwie Google, machst du in der Regel deinen Filter und sagst so, der Kai darf nur das mir schicken, was der Kai auch wirklich mir schicken darf. Und da baut man dann aus diesen Datenbanken, die es im Internet gibt, Filter zusammen, die halt wirklich sicherstellen, dass da nicht zum Beispiel ich plötzlich dir sage, ich hab das Internet bei mir, sondern du sagst, ich nehm nur genau das, was der Kai wirklich selbst hat. Und Malaysia Telekom hat zum Beispiel so das Internet von einem großen Carrier bezogen, der nicht so wirklich diese Filter-Sessions drauf hatte. Und Malaysia Telekom hat dann einen Konfigurationsfehler gemacht und hat dann dem großen Carrier erstmal gesagt, so hallo, ich hab hier das gesamte Internet. Und der große Carrier hat wegen den Filtern gesagt, so cool, du hast das ganze Internet, ich nehm das mal alles an und trag das bei mir ein und erzähl das auch noch allen anderen Leuten. Und so hat es dann dazu geführt, dass plötzlich mal für ein paar Minuten das gesamte Internet gedacht hat, alles ist bei Malaysia Telekom. Aber da ist es gar nicht.
Okay, abgesehen von diesen Filtern, gibt es da keine Mechanismen, gibt es da keine Tabelle, wo grob drin steht, wer was darf, wer was kann und was tatsächlich plausibel ist. Also gut, das sind natürlich auch Filter, aber ich könnte mir eine Authentifizierung da vorstellen.
Du baust dir deine Filter von da, wo du deine IP-Adresse herbekommst. Ganz am Anfang haben wir kurz diese RIPE erwähnt, wo man IP-Adressen beantragen kann. Und die sagen dann halt auch, wir geben jetzt diese IP-Adresse an dich zum Beispiel. Und dann tragen sie in eine Datenbank ein, dass du diese IP-Adresse benutzen darfst. Und du darfst auch anderen Leuten sagen, dass du sie benutzt. Und idealerweise aus dieser Datenbank, dieser großen Tabelle sozusagen, baut man dann diese Filter. Und ich sag dann, dass ich nur das von dir annehme, wo RIPE sagt, dass du das auch announcing darfst.
Das gibt es beim RIPE, aber es scheint es nicht weltweit zu geben.
Nee, das gibt es in ein paar Regionen. In ein paar Regionen nicht so wirklich. Aber es bringen halt die besten Filter nichts, wenn die Leute, die den Router administrieren, diese Filter nicht drauf werfen und das nicht checken, was sie annehmen.
Und letztendlich, ihr sagt mehr als Filter einbauen, ist da als Vorsichtsmaßnahme nicht zu machen. Und wir werden auch in Zukunft mit Schwankungen zu rechnen haben.
Na ja, es gibt da Bestrebungen, so einen Kram zu signieren und so weiter. Das ist allerdings... Na ja, wenn du halt nicht filterst, dann filterst du nicht. Wie du jetzt am Ende filterst und ob du das jetzt signiert machst oder unsigniert oder was auch immer, ist halt ein soziales Problem.
Also, warum sollten Leute solche Signaturen checken und prüfen, wenn sie es nicht mal schaffen, sich in Lister einzutragen vernünftig und das zu pflegen?
Es ist ja sehr lustig, dass solche Leute die Infrastruktur quasi der ganzen Welt... Vielleicht ist nicht nur die Cloud das einzige, was keine gute Idee ist, wenn ich mir das so anhöre.
Internet abschalten und was mit Holz machen. Eine ganz tolle Methode.
Und Menschen mit Facebook-Schneggern.
Aber Menschen vergessen sich dann...
Du guckst dir Technik näher an und je tiefer du dir Technik anguckst, desto mehr hast du Respekt davor, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Also das Internet ist ein riesiger Haufen an Netzwerken, wo es ein Wunder ist, dass es so tut, wie es heute noch tut, wenn man sich mal anschaut, dass alles auf diesem BGP-Protokoll basiert, was eigentlich ziemlich überarbeitet werden müsste, mal dringendst.
Okay, das heißt, es basiert alles auf Menschen. Das heißt, du willst mir tatsächlich sagen, das Internet steht da, weil sich ein Haufen Leute regelmäßig zum Saufen treffen.
Zum Beispiel, aber auch weil...
Das nennt sich dann Beering-Policy.
Weil einfach Leute Dinge daran tun. Der Haken an der Sache ist, dass an diesem Internet nicht 10 Leute sind oder 100. Und man sagt, man trifft sich jetzt mal alle und schließt sich im Hotel ein. Und dann hackt man und macht ein neues Protokoll, was viel sicherer ist. Sondern da sind mehrere 10.000 Leute oder 100.000 Leute involviert, die Teile von diesem Internet administrieren. Und da kann man halt schlecht sagen, so am 31.12. um 0 Uhr schalten wir jetzt mal BGP aus und machen das neue Routing-Protokoll 2.0 mit Cloud Beta sonst was an. Und dann wird alles awesome und alles stabil. Sondern man sieht ja schon bei V6, wie lange das dauert, bis sich das adaptiert. Also kann man da grob mal drüber nachdenken, wie lange das dauern würde, wenn jetzt alle Leute BGP ausschalten und was anderes anschalten müssten.
Wann war denn der letzte Wechsel, als das passiert war? EGP nach BGP?
Ich glaube, ich war da noch nicht dabei. Also es war vor langer, langer Zeit.
War das Internet noch klein genug, dass man das mal eben so machen konnte? Und das ist deutlich über 15 Jahre her.
Worauf ich eigentlich aber auch hinaus wollte, ist so ein bisschen, das ist sehr viel, also die Tatsache, dass das IP-Verkehr von A nach B oder überhaupt Internetverkehr von A nach B fließen kann, hat sehr viel mit Leuten zu tun, die bei Anbietern sitzen und miteinander reden, dass dieser Datenaustausch dann auch tatsächlich eingerichtet wird.
Das Ding nennt sich halt Community.
Das klingt halt so ein bisschen lustig in meinen Ohren, wenn man sich vergegenwärtigt, dass da natürlich auch Kohle im Spiel ist. Da dann das Wort Community zu nabbe zählt doch mal.
Du hast da ganz viele verschiedene Layer, die beteiligt sind. Dieser Kohle-Layer ist das Management, das ist da oben irgendwo drüber. Das Schöne ist, ich als Forscher bin ja nicht so der Operator-Typ, der da jetzt wirklich Netze betreiben hat. Ich versuche das ja alles nur zu verstehen. Wenn ich auf so Konferenzen fahre, dann sehe ich, wie das funktioniert. Das heißt, da kommen Leute zusammen, die arbeiten bei verschiedenen Providern oder Carry-On oder Telcos. Diese Jobs ändern sich. Ich bin heute mal bei der Firma A, morgen bei der Firma B. Aber ich behalte ja die Kontakte, ich kenne die ganzen Leute. Aus so persönlichen Beziehungen entstehen dann z.B. Peerings. Ich treffe mich bei so einer Konferenz und sitze abends beim Bier zusammen.
Oder in der Sauna.
Oder in der Sauna und stelle fest, wir sind doch im selben Data Center und tauschen viel Traffic aus, lass doch mal einen Peerings aufsetzen. Das ist eben genau das, wie auch diese IXPs, diese Net Exchange Points, am Anfang entstanden sind. Es haben sich Leute getroffen, die gemeint haben, lass mal irgendwie zusammenschalten. Und das funktioniert so ähnlich heute immer noch. Das ist in verschiedenen Ländern, funktioniert das verschieden gut. Die Konferenz, in der ich so gesehen habe, ist vor allem dieses Ride Meeting, was da ein paar Mal im Jahr stattfindet. Da ist das eigentlich eine ziemlich nette Atmosphäre immer. Die Leute sind sehr freundlich. Und auch wenn sie unterschiedliche Positionen vertreten, vertreten sie sie zum Teil im Namen ihrer Firma. Das ist allerdings auch relativ klar und das versteht auch jeder. Und beim nächsten Meeting hat er vielleicht seinen Arbeitgeber gewechselt und man kann wieder ganz anders miteinander reden und andere Agreements da irgendwie machen. Gleichzeitig kann das natürlich auch eine Gefahr bedeuten, wenn das nicht funktioniert und sich zwei Leute nicht grün senden. Weil dann kommt vielleicht kein Periodenzustand, obwohl das sinnvoll wäre.
Das heißt, es kann sein, dass auch bedeutende Provider nicht miteinander peeren, weil sich Leute nicht...
Ich mag das im Einzelfall nicht ausschließen, kann da aber jetzt konkret kein Beispiel nennen.
Spannend. Na gut. Dann würde ich euch eigentlich nochmal fragen, was haben wir noch vergessen?
Adressknappheit?
Stimmt. Na dann, Adressknappheit. Ich hab gehört... Du hast noch drei Minuten, um dich über Adressknappheit auszulassen.
Mehr Zeit als Adressen.
Weil du es angesprochen hast.
Du wolltest natt machen.
Ich will keinen natt, ich hab keinen natt. Also wir haben dieses Internet, um miteinander reden zu können, hat jedes Gerät eine IP-Adresse. Und diese IP-Adressen sind bald alle.
Die sind endlich so. Diese IPv4-Adressen, wo man eben 255 mögliche Zahlen hat an vier Stellen, die sind halt irgendwann alle. Das ist jetzt so passiert.
Na jetzt kann ich halt das machen, was ich zu Hause mache. Zu Hause habe ich halt auch mehrere Geräte in meinem Netzwerk.
Und hast V6 angemacht?
Moment, ich will dir erstmal das Böse erklären. Das, was alles kaputt macht. Und ich habe mehrere Geräte, aber mein Provider gibt mir auch nur eine, welche Verbindungen das sind und Stück für Karten zurückkommen. Das kann ich jetzt zu Hause auf meinem Plastikrouter machen. Das kann ich aber auch in größer machen. Wenn ich jetzt so ein Provider bin.
Mobilfunknetz?
Ja, Mobilfunknetz oder halt auch jetzt tatsächlich beim klassischen DSL oder Kabelmode. Ich habe halt mehr Kunden als IP-Adressen und die Kunden wollen alle gleichzeitig online sein. Dann mache ich halt das auch in groß. Das heißt, ich bekomme die Datenpakete von meinen Kunden, klatsche dann eine andere IP-Adresse da vorne davor und schicke das so weiter. Und dann muss ich dieser Router merken, wo das hergekommen ist und zurückschicken. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt aber plötzlich zweimal diese Adress-Translation, dieses NAT. Ich habe das einmal zuhause bei mir bei dem Plastikrouter und dann nochmal bei meinem Provider.
Und vor allen Dingen der Kunde, wenn ich das nicht verstehe, ist dann eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig im Internet.
Genau, der Kunde ist dann hinter zweimal diesem NAT und wenn er dann versucht irgendwie Online-Spiele zu spielen, die auch eingehende Verbindungen brauchen, oder wenn er versucht, Google Maps aufzurufen, das sehr sehr viele Verwendungen parallel aufbaut.
Oder wenn er versucht, über das Internet zu telefonieren, was ihr eine dumme Idee ist, weil über das Internet kann man nicht telefonieren.
Genau, dann geht das halt alles plötzlich nicht mehr. Und die Kunden werden plötzlich unzufrieden. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich halt die Provider, die unheimlich viel Geld investieren in diese Care-Rate-Nuts, so heißen diese Gerätschaften, die das machen, die aber auch nicht glücklich werden damit, weil sie an einem Punkt geschlafen haben. Das war die Einführung von IPv6. Das Protokoll ist mittlerweile doch deutlich über einen Jahrzehnt alt.
Und es gibt da die ganz einfache Lösung, na gut, wenn uns die Adresse zu klein ist, dann machen wir die Adressen halt größer.
Genau. Und bei IPv6 haben wir halt genau das gemacht. Wir haben nicht mehr 32 Bit, sondern wir haben 128 Bit pro Adresse.
Wann kann ich das haben?
Jetzt, also seit über 10 Jahren.
Wann kann ich das wirklich haben?
Geht zum richtigen ISP. Also gleichzeitig gibt es Leute, die das ausrollen, als wäre es das Selbstverständlichste auf der Welt.
Und auf der anderen Seite?
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Leute, die sehen da einen Berg Kosten, der da entgegenkommt, um die wieder reinzuholen, bauen kann und ob die Technik das nicht kann. Und man muss dann auch erstmal ganz viel Arbeit reinstecken, weil vor 10 Jahren war das ja nicht nötig, dass man das brauchte. Und jetzt drückt das und jetzt muss halt sowas schnell gebaut werden. Viel mehr Geld plötzlich.
Weil natürlich auch die ganzen Berater, die das können, jetzt ausgebucht sind.
Okay, ich sehe. Das ist also alles noch ganz, ganz traurig. Und ich glaube auch zu V6 können wir eigentlich noch mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Soweit erstmal danke an Kai, Nibler und Mutags. Dann jetzt zum Abschluss noch ein paar Hausmeistereien. Wir müssen eigentlich das Camp ankündigen. Nochmal ankündigen. Ich weiß, wir haben das schon ein paar Mal gemacht.
Findet das überhaupt statt, so ohne Tickets?
Gibt es da überhaupt Internet auf diesem Camp?
Ja, tatsächlich gibt es auf diesem Camp Internet. Wir werden uns das auf einer Hochspannungsleitung rausholen.
Das heißt, wir können uns freuen, dass auch hier wieder Infrastruktur benutzt wird, um Glasfaser in die Wallachie zu bringen. Nämlich nach Mildenberg, wo wir vom 13. bis zum 17. August im Ziegeleihepark das Chaos Communication Camp veranstalten werden. Vermutlich mit Internet, hoffentlich auch bald mit Tickets. Alles weitere dann unter events.ccc.de. Ansonsten haben wir natürlich noch anzukündigen, was wir immer haben, weitere Vorträge, wie Kai das jetzt gemacht hat. Die Reihe nennt sich Datengarten. Der nächste, mit der Nummer 55, findet am Dienstag den 14.07. ab 20 Uhr hier in diesen Räumen im CCCW statt. Ansonsten jeden zweiten Dienstag im Monat. Oder manchmal gibt es auch Termine außer der Reihe. Da könnt ihr dann den Twitter-Account at clubdiscordia oder der entsprechenden Mailingliste folgen. Schaut einfach mal vorbei, Berlin.ccc.de. In jedem Fall für euch die Anlaufstelle.
Das auch zweimal die Woche, nämlich Dienstags und Donnerstags beim clubdiscordia.
Genau, dort könnt ihr einfach vorbeischauen und Kontakt aufnehmen mit der restlichen Community, die hier so im Club rumschwirrt. Gut, und damit werden wir eigentlich am Ende der Sendung angelangt. Und mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal, dann wieder auf Ritz mit Markus Richter.
Lasst euch nicht verschlüsseln und überwacht immer eure Backups.